The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? Today we're
going to be speaking a little bit,
having a conversation about Iran and
what we think might happen next. And I'm
joined, of course, with none other than
the star himself, a man who's been
covering current affairs and people all
over the world have been tuning into his
fantastic channel talking about all
kinds of issues. Iran related, Pakistan
related, India related, Israel related,
Palestine related. We're talking about
Zeshan Ali.
How are you? Alhamdulillah. How you
doing? Thank you for that lovely
introduction. Sometimes we have to say
the good things, you know.
Alhamdulillah. Sometimes we have to say
good things. Alhamdulillah. Now, let's
start by asking you, what do you think
um is going to happen next? We've
already seen, okay, to summarize, we've
already seen some days of
barging and intercepting of the Iron
Dome and the David Sling and the
multiple layers and the arrow um by a
country in Iran that has probably got
one of the most, if not the most
advanced indigenous missile creation in
the Muslim world.
Um, in terms of ballistic missiles, I
think the conversation is uh more
limited. I think that there's no
question that Iran has the best
ballistic missiles probably in the
Muslim world and probably even in the
Middle East. Um, they could they could
even compare and be better than the
Jericho missiles that the Israelis have.
Maybe yes, the Jericho ones can reach a
further target, but in terms of
precision and power, you could make the
argument for the Iranian one. And
they've been penetrating, haven't they?
They've uh gone through and gone to
Hifad. They've gone to Tel Aviv and
different places. Um it has shown that
it's not impenetrable this missile
defense system of the Israelis. It's not
an impenetrable system. And that's one
thing I think that's taken a lot of
commentators by surprise considering how
much um emphasis Israel has uh put on
this particular missile defense system.
But there's escalation here. What do you
think is going to happen next? I think
you made a really good point towards the
towards the end which was that it's
taken a lot of people by surprise that
they have been able to penetrate the
Iron Dome because the Iron Dome has been
marketed as
kind of uh divine in some words that it
cannot be penetrated. That's it. Israel
is, you know, it it's a lot of
exaggeration mixed with a lot of
hypotheticals
that's used to keep to keep people at
bay. Mhm. However, like you mentioned,
in the last uh few days, we have seen
the Iron Dome being penetrated a lot and
penetrated
precisely as well. Just today we found
out that one of the headquarters of
Mossad the unit A200 and certain you
know intelligence places have been
attacked. So that is definitely
happening to such a degree that is never
happened to Israel before has it? It's
it's like a lot of commentators are
saying Israel is just used to fighting
defenseless children. Yeah. They haven't
had to face in recent times a formidable
opponent and they've become too lax.
They become too lazy like we saw
recently with the whole Palestine thing.
All they could do was produce these uh
their military was too were too busy
doing these dancing Tik Tok videos. They
become a joke. However, if you now
contrast that with Alon Levy who used to
be the former spokesperson of Israel, he
debated Mahassan. debated Mahi Hassan
and he made a lot of media appearances
on behalf of Israel. We saw him come out
of his home in a vest and pajamas saying
my neighborhood has just been blown up.
So the the contrast is unbelievable.
It's it's extraordinary. It's the mental
weakness of a lot of the Zionist
proponents. It's like you've just
essentially leveled
um Gaza to the ground. You've killed
75,000 people. You've killed 20,000
children, babies. I don't know how many
thousands you've killed and probably
that's a conservative estimate, right?
And now you know not even a not even a
percentage of a percentage of 1% of that
has been afflicted to your uh cities and
look at how you're behaving. Look, it's
you know you know what the most sad
thing is? It's insulting the
intelligence of the American people.
That's what it is. Oh yes. Glenn Gle
Glenn Grenwald Greenwald he's a very
famous um political commentator him
amongst many others have picked up on a
clip as same with George Galloway was
telling Pers Morgan to his face that
three months ago Tulsi Gabbard who was
the head of the uh the American
intelligence agency said they do not
have nuclear weapons. She made it clear.
Yeah. Now, Donald Trump when he's cut
short his G7 meeting, he's on the plane
and someone asks him, "Your own
intelligence head was saying this." He
goes, "No, no, no. She got it wrong."
So, I'm I'm sorry. One second. One
second. So, on the one hand, you have
your intelligence agency whose sole
function it is to be intelligent and to
know things that you can't know. Mhm. So
this bumbling buffoon knows more than
the intelligence agency. You know, you
know the reality is the reality is
they're trying to pull put the wool over
the people's eyes because the people
knows bro they know 30 years ago exactly
he's been saying the same thing.
Netanyahu he published a book in which
he said yeah about 3 4 years left 3 4
years left. That was like 10 or 15 years
ago. Yeah. Yeah, I mean there's a few
things on this is um the the pretense of
like you know going in because of
nuclear weapons is weapons of mass
destruction mass destruction is the same
kind of regurgitation that we've heard
in the Iraq war which was one of the
biggest um I would say it was the major
downfall of Tony Blair. You know, it
seems to me like if Donald Trump does
decide, and this is one of the
eventualities, although I do think it's
more remote, if they do decide for
direct military involvement, it will be
as much, if not more, an Achilles Hill
for him as it had been for uh Tony Blair
at the time. Because people don't
realize before the Iraq war, Tony Blair
had a a serious momentum actually. you
know he was he propounded this third way
of labor and all these kind of things
and and you know they were really strong
um even from a foreign policy
perspective what they done and Kosovo
was very much respected in the
international community so he had done
this and it basically broke his legacy
it destroyed his career and it made him
a laughingtock this is likely to happen
even more so to Donald Trump if he does
decide and I do think it's a remote yeah
eventuality. But nevertheless, I I I
100% agree with you. Why? Because people
are showing when Trump was coming into
office. One of his main things was to
set himself apart from his predecessors.
Yeah. Anti-war. I'm president of peace.
I want to stop all this. I want to put
America first. Mhm. Now, that's the
reason why when you've got MAGA
proponents like Charlie Kirk, when they
are putting polls on their Twitter ex
page, who hasn't who hasn't responded to
my challenger? He hasn't. He's a coward.
Coward. Yes, absolute coward. He's a god
darn coward.
So, he put out a poll on his page. The
reason why I'm bringing him up is
because he's very kind of uh he was
instrumental. One of the guys that was
there at the Trump campaign helping him
get elected. is up there and with him he
put out a poll asking are you for us
joining and attacking Iran or against a
resounding 90% said on his poll they are
against thereafter he did another poll
saying what would happen to MAGA i.e
Trump's vote base and 55% said it would
become divided and that's why Tucker
Carlson is publicly against Donald Trump
to such a degree that he is publicly
rebuking him and Trump is responding.
Trump is publicly rebuking Trump Coulson
and then you've got other right-wing
commentators like the Hodgej twins
saying I don't get it. Why is he
responding like this? So Candace Owens
is also against it. Nick Fuentes, Steve
Bannon. These are heavy weights in the
rightwing movement that are against this
and they are consistent. Now Trump
understands this. That's why he's losing
it on ex responding to Tucker Carlson
and getting angry over here. Losing it
with Emanuel Macron that oh he's because
he wants to broker a ceasefire
supposedly Macron said and Trump is
rebuking him saying no no no he doesn't
know
because Trump seems to be wanting to use
this as a leverage for negotiation. I
mean, a lot of people are saying, in
including his best friend, well, ex-
best friend Elon Musk, that he was on
the Epstein files. Well, people are
definitely questioning that someone's
got something on him for somebody to do
such a U-turn. And Putin, in one of his
interviews, he said some American
presidents are really good people until
they get elected. When they get elected,
then the people in the black suits come
in and then everything changes.
So you mentioned Putin. Okay. Uh there's
two kind of narratives relating to Iran
in the region. One of them is that they
have Iran has a strong relationship with
Russia and with China and of course with
Pakistan as well. Um but more so for our
purposes here you know Russia and China
two superpowers in a sense. And the
other ones actually that's that's an
overrated overestimated kind of thing
and in fact Iran is quite isolated.
um they don't really have that much
backing from China and from Russia and
so some people think that if there was
kind of intervention from United States
or things escalated to a very high level
that if not directly indirectly you know
China would get involved by giving some
you know weaponry or something to them
uh as they did with Pakistan and others
say no they're not invested as much with
Iran as they are with Pakistan where do
you stand on this what do you I think is
the correct
view really on this. So when it comes to
Iran what's very important to understand
is America their attention if you look
in the last 3 4 months has been on
China. Let's ban Tik Tok. Let's ban
Huawei. Let's put tariffs on them. Then
there were these tariff wars and then
they keep bringing up Taiwan and these
disputed regions. So America is hellbent
on making China's life miserable. Yeah.
On the other hand, you've got America
and the European block that's hellbent
on making Russia's life miserable. If
now something else is happening that's
taking their attention away from that,
it makes sense for Russia and China to
assist in that diversion to drain the
resources of their opponents as well as
their time and efforts. So, it gives
them enough time and opportunity to
regroup and restrategize. So they
definitely will be happening. However,
when it comes to economy and stuff like
that, China is heavily rellying upon
western values and companies like people
are saying Black Rockck and these are
Vanguard and these companies are heavily
invested in China and they influence
China significantly. So if China was to
do something they would have to do it
underground otherwise it would fair
consequences and you know consequences
would result and if China was to help
anybody you know as blatantly they would
have helped Russia. So, but people know
that they are supporting Russia
underground. But I mean, realistically
speaking, they have to help Iran because
Iran, China, Russia are the counter
power to America. So, definitely I
believe they'd be assisting them in some
means. It's not going to be as overt and
as obvious as possible. Um but then
let's see because only what would be
different with like Iran and Iraq. So if
if if Iran is so instrumental,
why did these big great powers allow
Iraq to be overrun by the United States
and not have a similar kind of dealing
with them? That's a good point. That's a
good point. But at that time I don't
think China and Russia were getting the
pressure that they are getting today.
Okay. from half of the globe. I mean
what Russia's being put through, what
China is being put through, China knows.
I mean, you've got documentaries done by
John Pilj that are showing that there is
a noose of American bases around China.
China should know that there is
something impending and that's why they
are very kind of cautious with Pakistan
as the you know utilizing them as a
counterbalance and see and there is a
lot of give and take and Pakistan's
neighbor is Iran as well. So it's within
the interests of Pakistan that there is
uh stabilization on that on that front
because India of course they've got
issues with India on one side they're
not exactly best buddies with
Afghanistan and uh you know the
surrounding them they have issues um
even economically as well. So it makes
sense for them to assist Iran in some
way without knowing. So I guess what I'm
saying is that if people realize that
when when and if Iran was to go down
then it's open season in the Middle East
because Israel believes in something
called greater Israel. Yeah. Like the
promised land. It incorporates Mecca,
Medina, Saudi Arabia, Jordan, Syria, all
of these places. And we know countries
like Jordan are very weak. Yeah. Egypt
very weak militarily. Yeah. uh compared
to I would say Iran. Am I wrong? I would
say that um definitely from a ballistic
missile that missile perspective um you
know the you know this Egypt is only
allowed to have uh missiles that go 300
kilometers. Okay. Um it's a part of the
Camp David Accords. It's not really part
of the the Accords per se, but what it
is is that United States gives them like
1 point something billion per year,
right? What do they do with that? and
they are the ones who supply them with
the F-16s and Rafals.
Um that's their main kind of like five
come from France. Oh yeah, of course.
Yeah, Rafals come from France, but they
get F-16s from America. And then you've
got the um the missiles that they get
can only go 300 km, which I don't know
is it from London to Birmingham or
something like that. Wow. So, in order
for Egypt to be able to attack uh Israel
with missiles, they'd have to
essentially get into Gaza or let's say
get on the on the tip of the Sinai
Peninsula and they would have to kind of
move all the way. And by the time they
do all of that, then Israel would have
spotted them a long time ago. So,
they've they've orchestrated it and
they've they've created an architecture
with Egypt. I mean, in terms of the the
fighter jets, I think you could make an
argument that the the Air Force, the
Egyptian Air Force, is somewhat
formidable. It's not as uh formidable as
the Israeli one in terms of technology,
but it's somewhat formidable because of
these weapons. But once again, if you
can't use because the thing is a lot of
it like the Rafals and the F-16s, they
have these system updates, you know, and
you know, the Americans and the French
are responsible for those. And so if
they jam them, they can jam the systems.
They can they can do certain things.
Now, they do have other Russian uh air
jets as well. They can use them, but
they won't be as effective in this way.
That's why actually Egypt wanted to buy
some new um planes from Russia which
prompted a kind of um response from
America and they they tried to stop that
because they knew it could change the
balance of power. Now what Pakistan did
that Egypt didn't do which was very good
is it diversified its portfolio and it
got weapons from China. M Egypt tried to
go in this kind of direction with Russia
a little bit but it didn't do a proper
job. Um so right now in terms of what
Egypt would have to do let's say
hypothetically if it were you know
allied in that way and if it were
politically um a ad you know hostile to
Israel for now they would have to go in
boots on ground or they would have to
use the air force. Uh they couldn't
really use uh missiles. The best country
in the Middle East to use missiles is
Iran because they have developed they
they understood that this face off was
very likely and they've developed
missiles that are very technologically
advanced, world class um probably second
only to you know China and South Korea
and you know America and these kinds of
things but it's up there and Russia is
probably tier two like after that it's
the Iranian missiles and so on. um is
comparable with the Israeli equivalent
for example. So their missiles will go
through. The Egyptian missiles will not
go through. It will not even reach
Israel frankly. I I think another point
to add would be that if Israel does gain
control over Iran, that threat is
neutralized because Israel requires the
help of America. It's constantly
knocking on the door of America. And if
that threat becomes neutralized and then
they're able to take more weaker
opponents then Israel becomes
um unleashed from America's power like
one analyst put it and he said that
Israel will become more uncontrollable
for us and at least now to some degree
we had influence and control over it but
you look look at the UK and compared to
Israel UK doesn't have any you know
significant pull over Israel that say
America does um but once Israel becomes
comes more stronger. They believe
they're the chosen ones. You know what I
mean? And if you believe that you're the
chosen one, then that's it. Like
everybody else is there's an expans
there's an expansionist policy. Yeah.
Yeah. Um but I do think that like for
for example another contender here is is
is Turkey as well and Turkeykey's air
force their drones if there were to be
some kind of a face off face off between
Turkey and Israel. Um I don't think I
don't think Israel would want to have a
kind of like a multi-
um frontier face off with all these
countries around them because
Turkeykey's formidable and probably is
the favorite in that like in terms of
cuz where would where would the um where
would the war take place? It would take
place over the sea. It wouldn't take
place on the land with Turkey. They
they'd meet on the sea and it's but
Turkey is very restricted like the the
awam the people know what happened in
Syria and yeah and that's another place
it could take place. I mean Turkey can
go into Syria and they can go through
the Golan as well. Um so I mean look um
I I think they realize look this is the
first time Israel has been punched by
heavyweight. It's a heavyweight power
that's been fighting lightweights all
its time. Hamas is a militia group. It's
unbelievable that they're even in the
fight for this long. It's unbelievable.
It's shocking that two years on Hamas is
even in the fight. And I'm seeing in
Alazer Arabic, you know, that they've
got they they're shooting down uh or
they're blowing up uh tanks and stuff
like that. They're sniping people. I'm
not sure if you've seen those videos,
but how can they still be doing this,
you know, after 2 years? This is a
militia group. This is homemade
equipment. This is not a state actor.
This is not a territorial army. And even
Iraq was not a walk in the park for
them. Afghanistan sure as hell was not a
walk in the park for them. They say that
if anybody wants to see what failure
looks like, imagine, you know, going in
removing a government, fighting them for
decade. Yeah. Only to replace the
previous government with the same
government. And and another point to be
noted here with this is that if you've
got a huge superpower like America, you
mentioned um Afghanistan,
insurgencies are very difficult to
maintain because the the home side is
the infinite player. So they they're
fighting for forever. Whereas
the side that's invading, the invading
side is the finite player. So in the
case of America going into Afghanistan,
they were unsuccessful. M like if we're
being honest like I know some people get
carried away with some hyperbolic
political analysis but the chances that
a 6 million you know country population
is going to be able to overrun say
Egypt's 120 million population is
actually slim to none zero actually they
can't you wouldn't even occupy it
there's too many people here's the thing
now that they've got daddy Trump behind
him who in the space of like an hour has
released three four tweets in which he's
saying we have control over the skies
and the people of Thran
They need to leave. Yeah. But even with
him, like they what they can do to these
countries, which is realistic, is what
they did to Iraq. They could destroy it.
They can take away its resources.
They're saying even Kmeni, we can easily
take him out and quite possibly if
they've taken out. Yeah, it's very
possible. This stuff is possible. Do you
know what I think is also possible? It's
a remote possibility, but I think it is
possible that they will they will
actually deploy a tactical nuclear
weapon in Iran
because they need to in order to get to
their, you know, where they the site of
where they say their nuclear weapons cuz
they put it underneath a mountain. And
most commentators say that you cannot
get down there unless you employ a
tactical nuclear weapon. So they may
think that okay, we need this is do or
die. We need to do this and this will be
the worst thing that happens. Even if
it's a remote possibility, it's worth
mentioning it's an eventuality at the
end of the day. They might do that. And
what might be a surprise to them is
that, and we've discussing this before
the show, but um what might be the
surprise to them is that Iran already
has nuclear weapons of mass destruction.
And not only they're smart, they would
do. Yeah. Yeah. I think it's a high
possib I agree with you, bros. Like they
would never declare it. If they had it,
they would never declare it. Just like
just like Israel. But the difference
with Iran is Iran has signed a
non-prololifer proliferation uh treaty.
They allow IAEA to come in and check
everything out. Israel does none of
that. It hasn't signed anything. It
doesn't allow anybody to come in. And
most people are unanimous. I I would say
it is unanimous that people are saying
that Israel has nukes. In fact, they
have something called the Samson option.
M how do you have the Samsung option
that's predicated on nukes if you're
saying with the other cheek you don't
have nukes it's a contradiction it is a
contradiction and you know this whole
nuclear discussion if it's true that
they feared the nuclear thing so much
right now which happens to be convenient
timing yeah then why not anything about
Pakistan Pakistan has about what is it
140 nuclear warheads and let's say look
you you've had hardliners
um premiership in in Pakistan in the
like say ' 80s and 90s you have what's
his name Z alhak for example right he
was a hardliner and so for an example
how plausible is it that another
hardliner could come into Pakistan there
could be a regime change and they could
decide you know what we're going to take
action towards uh Israel that's more of
a impending threat Pakistan is more of
an impending threat an imminent threat
to Israel than is than Iran is they look
they believe they're speaking to nursery
children. Yeah. These these questions
have have had ample rebuttals to them.
Uh and the Israelis have been told what
you believe that dropping a few bombs is
going to wipe out their nuclear
knowledge. Like is this what you're
having us believe? Then they have to
keep modifying their answers because
they don't believe that oh the people
are talking back and they're challenging
us. We thought we owned all your
Congress people. But then they switching
it now and they're saying no no no of
course we can't wipe out the knowledge
of the nuclear weapons and of course we
can't you know but even if we set them
back a little but that's not the
pretense that you've gone in with and
now what they're saying is and that's
why Netanyahu is addressing Iran the
Iranian people saying oh we want to
remove your regime we want a regime
change I'm sorry who are you who are you
to be dictating terms for which regime
is good or bad when you've been
conducting a genocide for the last
couple of years that you've got the
International Court of Justice and
International Criminal Court.
Yeah. Um putting out arrest warrants for
you people. These are international
courts. Like who are you? And who what's
the other country? The only country in
the world to have dropped an atomic
bomb. That's America right there. You've
got the most aggressive player in the
region in Israel. It's the most
aggressive player in the region. It's
bombed I don't know how many countries
they've bombed Yemen. They've bombed
Syria. They've bombed Lebanon and they
bombed the USS Liberty as well. Let's
not forget that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean this we're just talking about in
the last year and then Iran they've
bombed five countries in the last year
like No, but here's the point that I'm
saying that look they bombed all these
countries. Americans think that they
can't bomb them. What what about when
there was the British mandate in
Palestine? They used to bomb the the
British. The British used to get bombed.
The King David Hotel. People are saying,
"Why is it the queen never set foot in
Israel? Why in all of the years she
never set foot there? Why did or did
initially Charles have an issue with
them as well?" Why? Because they
remember type in and search terrorism
before 1980s. Yeah. more specifically
around the 1930s, 1940s, it was these
Zionists, the the Stern gang, Urggon.
Yeah. And um led by Menishm Been, you
know, you can read my book as I've
written the double standard as well.
It's got all these kind of things in
there as well. But on that note, on that
bombshell, no pun intended, we will
leave it there. We hope and pray that
the people of Iran, the people of
Palestine, the people of Syria, the
people of all that region are safe.
Amen. We pray that because this is a
difficult time for all of them. We hope
for peace in the region. We really do
because a lot of people have seen
suffering. But we also hope for
retribution. Oh yes. I have to say this.
Oh, we want this. And we want
retribution and proper just retribution
and justice to be delivered to the
abominable and condemnable state or
quote unquote state Zionist entity
Israel.
Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahel will give you even more.